>> '02 SAID IS HIS 19TH YEAR. 1
LOT OF STUDIO. IT IS GOOD.
IN THE BOX. REPORT. LOSED WITH
CLOCK AT TWO AND HE'S STILL ABLE
>> READY THINK SURPRISED
THE P PCHASED DOWN AND HE DOES
COMBO. IT
HARD, LITTLE SOFTER IN IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN KEPT IN PLAY.
INCREDIBLY UNBALANCED.
21 OF  GROUND.
FLYING
>> THE CLOCK TO DODI WAS
TRACKING THE ONE. YOU COYOU SEE
COLE ANTHONY ON THAT. ROWS IT.
GREAT. CONCENTRATE GOT HIT
TWICE BY  PICKS HIS POCKET.
BREAK OPPORTUNITY.
A.D. IS RU.
>> Jeff: GREAT ROTATION BY THE
LAKERS.
>> FROM 3, THEN TIME SINCE HE
HAD A TRIPLE. WE'LL SEE IF
KNOWS THIS.
STU: A WEAKSID FAME WITH THE
FIRST CHASE DOWN RIGHT UP.
>> SEXTON HERE, HE GOES ALL
THE CHASED DOWN. ERE IT IS. THE
FINISHES LEBRON REALLY, REALLY
FEELING GOOD JUST ABOUT OUT
AS HE JUST TAKES HIS THESE IME
SAID, LOOK. A
COUPLE OF TIMES S THROW IT DOWN
THUNDER. HAS A 2 BIG STEPS.
GET OUT OF HERE, BLOCKED BY
JAMES.
>>>>E YOU JUST
GRABBED IT OUT OF THE AIR AND
GONE THE OTHER DIRECTION. TO LB
AGAIN? THAT'S
WHAT THE 3RD REFERS. DON'T GET
LEBRON STILL OF 8. HIM. SORT OF.
SWITCH HANDS TO BE ABLE .
AGGRESSIVENESS FROMSTEAL
ATTEMPT. LEBRON OH, LOOK AWAY.
PASS TO AD AND HE SCORES.S.IT'S
INTO THE ZONES, HANDS THIS
TIME INSIDE TO ANTHONY DAVI
>> THROW DOWN. LEBRON BREAKS AW
AND